[Musik]
ok liegewiese politik zuschauer seid ihr
bereit für eine kleine herausforderung
hört euch mal die folgenden daten
anstellt euch ein land vor in den die
inflation jedes jahr um die 50 prozent
liegt in dem fast die hälfte der
bevölkerung in armut lebt in dem es nur
wenige hochwertige arbeitsplätze gibt
und in dem ein chronischer mangel an
devisen und investitionen herrscht ein
land das sich seit jahrzehnten in einer
fast ununterbrochenen wirtschaftlichen
politischen und sozialen krise befindet
und dessen produktionstechnologie mit
internationalen vergleich weit
abgeschlagen ist nein in diesem video
redende ausnahmsweise mal nicht über
russland sondern über das land der
gauchos argentinien am ende werdet ihr
jedoch verstehen wieso ist durchaus
starke parallelen zwischen diesen beiden
geografische weit voneinander entfernten
ländern gibt und wieso sich putin dieses
video besser ansehen sollte um zu
erfahren wohin seine politik der
wirtschaftlichen autarkie noch führen
wird nun ja argentinien befindet sich in
einer sehr schwierigen situation einen
teufelskreis aus dem es endlich
ausbrechen muss um seinen bürgern
endlich wieder jene lebensqualität zu
geben die sie einst ja genau argentinien
war nicht immer so arm es ist abgestürzt
und konzert jahrzehnten nicht mehr hoch
aber wenn du in diesem land etwas zu
sagen hätte ist welche entscheidungen
würdest du treffen an welchen
stellschrauben würdest du drehen
eine der änderungen die ich vielleicht
vielen von euch in den sinn kommt ist
die wirtschaft wettbewerbsfähig zu
machen und sich auch it außenhandel zu
konzentrieren was im angesichts so
vieler interner probleme auch sehr
naheliegend erscheint immerhin könnte
man so viele devisen verdienen neue
arbeitsplätze schaffen neue investoren
anlocken und viele weitere vorteile
erzielen im mittelfristig einen weg aus
der krise weisen soll zumal wir hier von
einer vorne sprechen die von vielen
regierungen auf der ganzen welt
erfolgreich angewendet wurde und spanien
über japan polen und china bis hin zu
singapur aber liebe visual politik
zuschauer es gibt ein land mit viel viel
mehr probleme als denen die wir bisher
beschrieben haben und in dem
internationale handel fast die ketzerei
behandelt wird
von welchen land entspreche nun spreche
von argentinien in einem land das gerade
so alle gestiegen außenhandel zu sein
scheint aber was sind die gründe hierfür
wie konnte ein einstmals reiches und
exportorientiertes land in den zustand
geraten in dem sich inzwischen bis
findet in diesem video werden wir diese
fragen beantworten und sagt wie so oft
mit einem schnellen blick in die
geschichte
vom globalisierungsgewinner zum
isolationisten
argentinien war bis ins 19 jahrhundert
hinein dünn besiedeltes und armes land
bis es von einem enormen sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung ergriffen
wurde man öffnete sich der welt und
millionen von einwanderern und
investoren kamen ins land auf diese
weise konnte besonders das
wirtschaftliche potenzial der
argentinischen pampa einem der größten
und fruchtbarsten anfrage bietet der
welt erschlossen werden
einem 19 jahrhundert noch weitaus
bedeutender faktor als heute besonders
durch die erschließung der pampa wurde
argentinien nach und nach zu einer der
comcom an der welt und zugleich zu einer
der wohlhabendsten länder der erde
jahren europäischer einwanderer kamen
ins land um ihr glück zu suchen und
volle eisenbahnwaggons transportierten
die früchte ihrer hände arbeit zu den
häfen von rosario und bolles 1
städte wuchsen der investitionstätigkeit
stieg rapide an und das land erlebte
seine eigene version des american dream
einen argentinischen traum doch das
alles begann sich zu ändern als 1929 der
große crash über die weltwirtschaft
hereinbrach eine krise die ihren
ursprung vor an den usa hatte aber bald
auf den rest der welt übergriff
[Musik]
dies löste in der weltpolitik eine große
welle von nationalismus
interventionismus und protektionismus
aus und wisst ihr was agentur war in
diesen fächern ein musterschüler
geradezu ein streber denn nach dem crash
suchten viele den grund ihrer probleme
in offenen grenzen dem goldstandard oder
eben auch im internationalen handel
der wirtschaftliche liberalismus und die
agrarexport wirtschaft die das land bis
dahin geprägt hatten galten als
überholtes modell die mehrheitsmeinung
gehen dahin dass sich das land auf einen
prozess autarker industrialisierung
konzentrieren sollte der es ihm
ermöglichen würde unabhängig von den
schwankungen der internationalen
wirtschaft erfolgreich zu sein
[Applaus]
diese ideen wurden mit den ausbruch des
zweiten weltkriegs und besonders mit der
machtübernahme von juan domingo perón im
jahr 1946 nochmals gefestigt
von da an schottete sich das land mit
der einführung der sogenannten import
substitution politik schrittweise von
der weltwirtschaft ab eine politik den
1970 er jahren ihren höhepunkt erreichte
eine makroökonomische standardwerk in
den 80er jahren dauernder wirkung
entfaltet hat war wie wir koller estro
mit dem unsrigen leben von albufeira
sein titel sollte ikonen schweren für
die argentinischen wirtschaftspolitik
mit den unsrigen leben mit dem leben was
uns gehört nun ja man kann von autarkie
ja denken was man will tatsache ist dass
die argentinischen politiker hart daran
gearbeitet haben das land vom rest der
welt zu isolieren allerdings mit einer
großen ausnahme bei der argentinien dann
doch sehr interessiert an
internationalen austausch ist und zwar
wenn es um harte dollar die wiesn geht
die der internationale währungsfonds an
argentinien überweist erst diesen märz
wurde das 22 hilfsprogramm aufgelegt
diesmal in höhe von 44 milliarden dollar
rückzahlung ungewiss
wir werden mit unserer schulden keine
verpflichtungen eingehen
aber dieses thema ist ein derartig
bizarrer weiterer alptraum argentiniens
das ist ein eigenes video verdient hat
an den ultras arbeiten also abo und
glocken nicht vergessen fakt ist bis
heute ist agent ihre weit davon entfernt
export zu fördern vielmehr bestehen
weiterhin sehr viele außen
handelsbarrieren ein absoluter
sonderfall in der internationalen
wirtschaftspolitik wir reden hier
wirklich über eine aufgabe welche die
argentinischen politiker sehr sehr ernst
genommen haben auch wenn die ergebnisse
katastrophal sind haben sie nicht nur
ihren kurs nicht geändert sondern ihre
bemühungen in dieser rechnung sogar noch
verstärkt und vor allem ist diese
katastrophale entwicklung noch nicht zu
ende das ist immer noch genau jene
politik der derzeitige präsident alberto
fernandez hartnäckig verfolgt
und ewig lockt der dollar
[Musik]
das überraschendste an fallada es ist
nicht dass die dortigen politiker davon
besessen sind importe unter dem vorwand
zu behindern die heimische industrie zu
fördern und den verlust von devisen zu
vermeiden schließlich haben das auch
schon viele andere regierungen rund um
den ganzen erdball oft getan was bisher
übrigens immer schlecht ausgegangen ist
unter anderem deshalb weil dadurch der
wettbewerb und die nutzung billigere
oder fortschrittlichere
produktionsmittel beeinträchtigt werden
und kostenvorteile durch effizientere
arbeitsteilung verloren gehen wird
gleichzeitig startete oligopole und
monopole entstehen welche konsumenten um
arbeitnehmer am ende gnadenlos schützen
können aber nein das auffälligste an
argentinien ist dass ein land dass
dringend dollars braucht seinen eigenen
exporte bestraft mit denen die heiß
begehrten devisen ins land geholt werden
könnten
stell dir vor du bist ein argentinischer
geschäftsmann und möchtest mit dem
ausland handel treiben und dann stehst
du fest dass seine regierung und alle
öffentlichen stellen sich mit misstrauen
behandeln und der jede menge steine in
den weg legen sowohl beim kauf als auch
der verkauf von gütern die frage ist nun
was genau macht da der argentinische
staat welche mechanismen nutzt die
dortige regierung um den internationalen
handel zu torpedieren nun der erste
faktor sind strenge
kapitalverkehrskontrollen das heißt dass
die argentinische regierung strenge
regeln für den kauf und verkauf von
dollars aufgestellt hat bereist
überweisungen in dollar sind stark
reglementiert denn die wir in einem
anderen video köstlich dargestellt haben
ist der dollar die referenz der
unterwelt und wäre damit bevorzugt als
währungs substitution also als schatten
währung genutzt wenn ein land keine
eigene oder nur eine extrem schwache
währung hat und die massiven kontrollen
haben zur etablierung zweier
wechselkurse inland geführt
auf der einen seite gibt es den
offiziellen wechselkurs für den
argentinischen peso der zum zeitpunkt
der dreharbeiten bei etwa 119 pesos pro
dollar lag und auf der anderen seite
gibt es den freien wechselkurs des
informellen marktes besser bekannt als
der blue dollar kurs hier bekommt man
fast doppelt so viel für einen dollar
etwa 204 ps man sieht also der
offizielle wechselkurs hat wenig mit
realität an den devisenmärkten zu tun
sondern wird von der regierung künstlich
niedrig gehalten die sich der wert am
freien markt entwickelt seht ihr in der
folgenden kraft
natürlich werden aber alle bankgeschäfte
am maßstab des offiziellen dollars
abgewickelt der wir gleich sehen werden
jedoch nicht so leicht zu bekommen ist
aber zunächst einmal was hat das
eigentlich mit den außenhandel zu tun
nun schauen wir uns zuerst an was mit
den importen passiert
[Musik]
der künstlich niedrig gehaltenen
wechselkurs erleichtert zunächst einmal
import welche die regierung auf diese
weise quasi subventioniert man muss
dafür jedoch erstmal an die günstig
bereitgestellten sie diesen kommen und
jedes unternehmen ob groß mittel groß
oder klein das waren aus dem ausland
importieren möchte steht in argentinien
vor einem labyrinth aus bürokratischen
hürden die es sehr schwierig machen die
benötigten diesen zu erhalten um
produkte importieren zu können müssen
unternehmen importlizenzen sogenannte lr
beantragen welche die argentinischen
behörden nach eigenem ermessen vergehen
mit anderen worten ob du eine bekommst
und importieren da ist hängt davon ab ob
der zuständige beamte deine
auslandsgeschäfte sinnvoll hält oder
nicht zu diesem zweck müssen die
unternehmen erklären warum und wieso sie
ausländische währung benötigen die
entsprechenden lizenzen rechtzeitig
beantragen schließlich beten dass der
zuständige beamte ihre gebete erhört und
ihnen die genehmigung erteilt
auf diese weise kontrolliert die
argentinische regierung indirekt die
menge an important die ins land kommen
und wenn die devisen der zentralbank ein
mal zur neige gehen wird der hahn
einfach zugedreht und es werden kaum
noch lizenzen erteilt die stellt
natürlich eine sehr schwere belastung
für heimische unternehmen da die von
heute auf morgen nicht mehr in der lage
sind glückliche rohstoffe und
vorprodukte aus dem ausland zu beziehen
[Musik]
das erklärt warum unternehmen in
argentinien mit wiederkehrenden
materialengpässen konfrontiert sind die
sich zum beispiel daran hindern ihre
produktion zu verbessern oder wichtige
maschinen zu reparieren der offizielle
dollar wechselkurs wird von der
regierung also zwar künstlich niedrig
gehalten was in porto zunächst einmal
erleichtert an vielen stellen jedoch
gewaltige probleme erzeugt denn neben
den genannten problemen besteht noch ein
weiteres dass das system noch
ineffizienter macht
einmal angenommen man verstünde sich
besonders gut mit der regierung und den
zuständigen beamten könnte man sich da
nicht privilegierten zugang für diesen
verschossen aber klar doch ein solches
system ist natürlich der ideale
nährboden für korruption und
günstlingswirtschaft ein problem wie es
in allen volkswirtschaften mit zentrale
lenkung auf dauert wie ihr seht also es
handelt sich um ein system das insgesamt
in effizienz und inflexibilität fördert
gut so viel zum import aber wie sieht es
beim export aus nun liebe zuschauer wenn
ihr ein produkt exportiert und damit
dollar verdient wird die regierung sich
zwangsweise in pesos umtauschen und zwar
zum offiziellen wechselkurs versteht
sich das heißt ihr bekommt für jeden
eurer dollar hast nur 119 pesos und
nicht die 204 des blue dollar kurses wie
auf den freien schwarzmarkt erklärt sich
der positive effekt auf importe also um
die wette dass fähigkeit der
argentinischen exporteure wird
untergraben und waren somit im land
gehalten
[Musik]
darüber hinaus ist argentiniens
wirtschaft durch die verfehlte
währungspolitik weit geht dollar
realisiert daher müssen sich die kosten
der unternehmen in vielen fällen nach
dem blut oder wechselkurs anders
ausgedrückt wenn ein unternehmen
beschließt seine produzierten waren zu
exportieren erhält er ist nicht nur käse
zu einem wechselkurs der gerade einmal
halb so hoch ist wie der marktwert der
dollar welche die regierung hinweg
genommen hat sondern es erhält auch die
hälfte dollars die erste produktion
ausgeben müssen fassen wir also kurz
zusammen es ergibt sich eine gleich
doppelt nachteilige situation für den
außenhandel importe scheinen wegen des
niedrigen offiziellen wechselkurses
attraktiv jedoch gibt ist nicht nur
viele zollitsch sowie der zugang zu den
nötigen die wiesn ist unsicher exporte
wiederum werden durch die regierung
bestraft indem du am ende schon vor
steuern nur die hälfte des umsatzes
erhältst verrückt nicht wahr dies in
kombination mit hohen steuern starren
arbeits vorschriften und vielen anderen
möglichen hindernissen im land erklärt
warum es trotz der niedrigen lohnkosten
praktisch keine multinationalen
unternehmen gibt die in dem land
investieren wollen um dort zu
produzieren ihr wahre den rest der welt
zu verkaufen das ganze ist also kein
wunder ich meine wer würde das in einem
solchen umfeld auch tun wollen
der mangel an ausländischen investoren
für dann natürlich dass sie das auch
wenig fach know how auf internationalem
niveau ins land fließt welches die
produktivität erhöhen könnte und aus
demselben grund gibt es auch keine
multinational konkurrenz gegen
arbeitgeber die höhere gehälter zahlen
und damit das allgemeine lohnniveau
verbessern würden aber passt auch denn
das ist noch nicht das ende der
geschichte da diese art von politik den
industriesektor des landes zerstört hat
ist argentiniens wirtschaft
hauptsächlich durch den export von
agrarprodukten wie für ein spiel geprägt
wobei diese natürlich auch von
argentinien selbst konsumiert werden und
um zu verhindern dass ausländische
käufer mit den einheimischen
verbrauchern konkurrieren gelten für
argentinische unternehmen gedeckelt
exportquoten mit anderen worten die
regierung zwingt die unternehmen einen
beträchtlichen teil ihrer produktion auf
dem heimischen markt zu verkaufen großer
zu preisen die von der regierung selbst
festgelegt werden das alles mag
rücksichtsvoll und menschenfreundlich
erscheinen das problem dabei ist aber
dass dadurch die devisen zuflüsse die
löhne und die investitionen in die
steigerung der produktionskapazitäten
für die bauen und agrarfirmen und es
sich einfach nicht in eine höhere
produktionsmenge oder gar qualität zu
investieren das ergebnis ist eine
klassische los los situation eine triste
ab dass spirale wer jetzt aber denkt
schlimmer könne es nicht mehr kommen das
ist noch lange nicht das ende der
traurigen argentinischen fahnenstange
[Musik]
in den letzten 20 jahren war
argentiniens exportschlager disco jahr
wurde ein produkt das besonders in china
geradezu verschlungen im land selbst
jedoch kaum konsumiert wird gehe ist die
exportquote also praktisch bedeutungslos
aber dachtet ihr diese tatsache würde
die autarkie bis es einen politiker
argentiniens aufhalten nun wenn ja habt
ihr euch gewaltig geehrt sojabohnen
produzenten können so viele sojabohnen
exportieren die sie wollen aber im
gegenzug zahlen sie eine sondersteuer
auf ihre ausfuhren während der blue
dollar also der freie dollar mit 204 ps
gehandelt wird erhalten exporteure kaum
70 jesus für jeden dollar den sie in
export einnehmen
das liegt daran dass die regierung die
dollars zu nicht zum offiziellen
wechselkurs in pesos ungerechnet und
sand eine zusätzliche steuer von 33
prozent erhöht von 200 die auf 70 pesos
pro exportierten dollar und wir sind
noch nicht fertig denn als ob das alles
nicht schon genug wäre für die regierung
immer neue bürokratische hürden die es
immer schwieriger machen im ausland zu
verkaufen so müssen agrarexporteure im
sogenannten marktteilnehmer register der
agrar und ernährungswirtschaft
eingetragen sein und das ist wahrlich
kein pappenstiel ist eine weitere
gigantische gelegenheit jede menge
papierkram dort müssen sich zum beispiel
angaben zu geplanten umsätzen im
kommenden jahr machen
finanzinformationen vorlegen um ihre
zahlungsfähigkeit nachzuweisen und
darüber hinaus detailliert über ihre
mitarbeiter und die von ihnen gezahlten
gehälter berichten sie müssen akribisch
überprüfen ob die unternehmen mit ihnen
zusammenarbeiten auch die anforderung
der argentinischen regierung erfüllen
und so weiter und so fort kurz gesagt
ein bürokratischer alptraum in einem
land das der unternehmer sowieso schon
voller albträumen ist
denn jedes unternehmen das exportieren
möchte muss sich mit zwei mächtigen
gewerkschaften auseinander setzen der
gewerkschaft der lkw fahrer und der
gewerkschaft der hafenarbeiter vor allem
ersterer wird zu allem überfluss von
einem mächtigen und gut vernetzten
familien klein geführt und an diesen
führt kein weg dabei wenn du deine waren
von a nach b bringen willst was den
transport teuer und die fahrpläne und
servicequalität für die kunden zum
glücksspiel werden lässt angesichts
solcher übermacht ist man natürlich
unmittelbar von diesen gewerkschaften
abhängig und wehe dem der sie gegen sich
aufbringt indem er sich verweigert sich
von ihnen verlangt und abgaben zu zahlen
der kann dann halt zusehen wie er seine
waren zu fuß an den mann bringt
[Musik]
und das sind nur ein paar beispiele
dafür wie der wirtschaftliche alltag in
argentinien exporteur in argentinien zu
sein ist also offenkundig eine fast
unmögliche aufgabe und die kennzahlen
bestätigen dieses wirtschaft ist eine
der am stärksten vom internationalen
handel abgeschotteten der welt es
handelt sich damit um ein land das sich
entschieden hat genau das gegenteil von
dem zu tun was die inzwischen
wohlhabendsten länder getan haben und
was ist es was selbst zu einem der
reichsten länder der welt gemacht hatte
nun dient es der welt als abschreckendes
beispiel dafür wie eine florierende
volkswirtschaft mit hohem lebensstandard
dauerhaft herunter gewirtschaftet werden
kann und ich hoffe auch dass ihr bei den
viel erwähnten stichworten wie import
situation und kapitalkontrollen die
parallelen zur aktuellen
wirtschaftspolitik planungen putins
erkannt habt über welche die vor kurzem
ein video gedreht haben dass ich euch
verlinkt werden findet ihr nicht auch
dass er sich mal etwas genauer über das
schicksal argentiniens informieren
sollte genauso wie sein kollege shipping
mit seinem motto in china für china über
das der focus ebenfalls ein video
gedreht haben aber so weit müssen wir
gar nicht gehen auch in europa gibt es
zahlreiche stimmen die eine konsequente
die globalisierung fordert aber kann es
sein dass all diese damen und herren
wirtschaftlich autarkie mit robustheit
verwechseln abschottung mit der
diversifizierung von lieferanten und der
bildung redundante ausfallsicherer
lieferketten was meint er hatte der
deutsche wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck recht als er beim
weltwirtschaftsforum hinter woods vor
allgemeinen tendenzen der abschottung
des nationalismus als antwort auf die
zahlreichen krisen bank oder wie könnt
ihr eurer meinung nach ein gelungenes
autarkie modell aussehen da sind wir
schon auf eure beiträge im
kommentarbereich gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat und
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habe
als ja gibt es einen leitpfosten und ein
unvergessliches auch mit glöckchen und
keines unserer videos und zu verpassen
natürlich wollen wir es auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den link
dazu findet ihr der beschreibung eine
video mach's gut du bist
[Musik]